[Music]
hi guys my name is Heinrich way come to
another coffee break with firm learning
today the weather is beautiful in Munich
we had a nice brunch this morning
together with a good friend of mine
who's actually an entrepreneur he has a
small company here in Munich employing
about 40 people and we talked about and
you employee in his company it's a new
guy he just left University he has good
grades seems to be quite good and and
confident and actually being able to do
the job way however for some reason my
friend doesn't seem to be just satisfied
with what he is doing at work and we
talked a bit about it and what the
reason might be because it wasn't
directly an easy to grasp and after some
time we came to the realization that
what this person was actually missing
was an ownership mindset so you may ask
yourself what is an ownership mindset
and an ownership mindset is a critical
mindset that on the one hand side many
new joiners and business lack if you
come from university often you do not
have that but on the other side this is
really what distinguishes we ever tried
the average professional from somebody
who really stands out and is perceived
as much better than all of the other
people in the team so an ownership
mindset is if you receive a task from
your team leader or another colleague
and you do not only try to somehow get
the task done but you feel completely
responsible from end to end to getting
to the result that is really needed and
why is that maybe a bit difficult for
you join us because of course in the
beginning of your career if you just
started your job in the early months and
maybe first one two or three years of
course you are you you do not have all
the knowledge of the organization maybe
you do not completely understand
everything so you to a certain extent
rely on your other colleagues you rely
on others checking your work making sure
that your work actually has the quality
that is needed and that it just is the
way it's supposed to be right and of
course to a certain extent
that's okay it's completely natural and
everybody will understand that as a new
employee you do not know everything from
the beginning you might even make
mistakes maybe the quality of your work
is not as good as maybe the work from a
more senior colleague
however the flip side of that is that
people start to rely on to depend on
that what I mean by that is the people
start to develop thoughts such as where
my team leaders reviewing it afterwards
anyway well if my team leads hazard and
he wants to change something where he
can still do that right or where you
know this is just the first draft I mean
it's just the first try for me let the
others that maybe refine it or you know
after myself many other people will
still review the document will still
ever look at it and if there's anything
wrong with that
then they will fix it right I mean this
is more or less consciously the mindset
that many people have especially in the
beginning of the career and the truth is
that many people do their work knowingly
that it's just not enough knowingly that
the end deliverable that they created is
just not meeting the standards and just
relying or just assuming that then other
people will pick up the slack that your
team did will then actually give it a
proper review and then fix all the
errors maybe change it to a way into a
lever that's actually enough and
sufficient for actually what's so quiet
and again from the perspective of your
team lead why on the one side you of
course understand that maybe a new
joiner isn't as good as somebody who's
more senior of course this is annoying
and is really bugging your time right
from my experience not from working in
consulting what of course happens
sometimes is that you request another
call it may be a support colleague of
yours to get something done to do
something and then you receive the
deliverable and it's just obvious that
this is not client ready deliverable
right it's just obvious that the other
person thought well you know hi anybody
in the end is going to fix it or the
other consulting colleague is going to
fix it and it's going to do all the last
changes that he maybe needs so it's
clear that the moment that the person
create
it just wasn't done and the P person
knew right that it wasn't done and this
is something that you should really
avoid a senior joiner from very early on
in your career you need to develop the
mindset that it's not only about getting
the traduce off your table right pushing
it out and just somehow completing them
but to make sure that every little thing
you do is actually at the level that
it's complete that actually wouldn't
require anybody else in your team in
your organization neither a colleague or
your team need to do any changes in
order for it to be at a level where it's
at least sufficient and okay right of
course there are different perspectives
maybe another colleague has another
opinion and would like to change
something a little bit but it should
always be at the level where you would
feel comfortable and actually handing
the deliverable to a client or to an
external party or somewhere else where
this actually might be needed in the
future and easy did a mindset heck that
I learned from my time with McKinsey
that you can employ here that are taught
to early young consultants is that you
should ask yourself the following
question
whenever you complete a deliverable a
certain task document or whatever you're
working on are you confident that you
could send this document to a board
member of your client and he would be
okay by reading this and nobody would
use face are you confident that your
work is ready to being sent to a board
member of your organization with your
name under it if you're not confident
that your work deliverables at this
level of quality then very likely you
just haven't done yet what is require
from you and you should go back and do
that of course it is great to have other
colleagues check your work to have a 4i
principle to make sure that no mistake
is left or anything like that but do not
rely on that do not rely on other
colleagues getting your work done you
are responsible for it you will deliver
it and you will bring it to a quality
that you can send it to a board member
of your organization so what
specifically can you do to develop this
ownership mindset and make sure that
your work quality is always read needs
to be now just a couple of
troops that I hope are helpful to you
right the first thing is if you find out
that you actually do not have the
information at hand
for you to complete the task and this of
course happens frequently maybe you need
other data input from other colleagues
right don't just push your work back to
your team leader and tell them sorry I
couldn't complete it because I just
didn't had all the information that I
needed right but reach out yourself to
these other colleagues to these other
departments do some research connect
everything you need and then go back to
your team need and tell them we're
beginning this wasn't sufficient but I
made sure that I have all these other
inputs and now this is the deliverable
that you really need another example
imagine your team lead came to you and
told you you need to create a certain
document a certain thing and by that you
should include three sort graphs for
instance with certain charts with a data
visualization that he felt like this is
what's required and had for a year but
by now crunching the numbers by digging
into the work you find out that actually
these three things that he asked you to
do just not enough and to actually
understand what's going on and to really
get the full grasp of the situation
it would just be required to include a
fourth diagram and to intruder piece of
work that you're working on right you
know what many new joiners do is changes
to exactly what they are told they
create the document include the three
diagrams and add add to the team lead or
the boss or whatever it's called in the
organization and then they're like well
I did everything what was asked for me
right and yes of course they did
everything but what has been asked from
you but in this instant that just was
enough it just wasn't enough to send it
to a board member of your organization
because for the board member he just
wouldn't have had the full picture and
and obviously if your team did know is
looking at it and thinking about this he
will likely come back to you and ask you
hey come on you know you should include
the fourth thing because this is just
important to do that and then of course
you can do that but it's always much
better and perceived much more
professionally if you think one step
ahead and directly include that because
you know that it's required to include
it right because nobody usually is as
deep into the details of the specifics
of the work that you currently
completing then yourself very often in
these situations
just not really possible for your team
need to foresee the things like that
would have needed to be included because
he just wasn't as deep as now you are
into the the matter spread so to
generalize a bit more what's really
important is that you ask yourself what
is actually the intention of this why is
somebody asking me to do something what
is he hoping to get out of that and then
make sure that the deliverable that you
produce actually enables the other
person or whatever the audience is for
the things that you're creating the
things you're working on to actually
answer these questions these problems
that they have if you are deliverable
isn't helpful in actually solving the
problem or answering these questions
then make sure to make all the changes
and adjustments in order to get there
right and of course if you feel more
comfortable then then go back to your
team leader and say hey I did one two
three but no I feel like in order for
this to be really helpful I think I
should do the fourth thing just in case
you want to make sure that he really
agrees as your supervisor but be
proactive and ask that make that
recommendation yourself instead of
waiting for others to tell you what you
already know as we try it so guys this
is really important if you want to be
successful in your early career but of
course also later on develop an
ownership mindset feel responsible for
the tasks that you're working on don't
just complete produce that somebody else
told you to actually complete but you
are owning it you are making sure that
your things you're working on actually
our great success if you do not adopt
this mindset it will be extremely
difficult for you to be successful and
pretty much any organization any
industry you work on get that done so if
you took any value out of this video
please press the like button and
subscribe to my channel here below if
you have any questions please leave a
comment you're also below I will answer
all your questions that appear in the
comment section I would be happy to do
so of course if you have any feedback or
suggestions on future videos let me know
as well and I will do my very best
I have many pieces of content planned
for the future
so again if you do not want to miss any
of
please subscribe here and you would be
then informed of whatever I produce
thank you for watching and have a good
day